I can still doing the exam I have no
idea [ __ ] it's going up
good morning boys
good way to start it's 6:40
good morning jetlag so much fun yay it's
a new day of new possibilities
today's the doctor thing I'm really
nervous I'm ready it's kind of pathetic
good lightning in here all right I'm
gonna have breakfast
I want to show you something here we
have my monthly beers you see this red
thing means shits going down alright
it's been going down for a long time and
it's almost catching back up this month
and I'm like come on you can go away
it's easy for youtuber to get like
really stuck on the statistics YouTube
is so there's so many aspects to it that
you can really beat yourself up to it
but it's there and it never goes away
and it's so easy to get obsessed with
all right price I'm gonna try and record
a video now because I have a little time
left I'm already really pissed off
because just not having your original
setup is really frustrating like the
game keeps crashing for some [ __ ]
reason all these things so they should
be good let's do this recording three
two one
we're all recording hey let's go Bridge
money I'm so pissed it doesn't work this
computer is not powerful enough it keeps
dropping framerate youtuber problems
hashtag that's a hashtag I'm not
fingering you okay great I'm gonna I
don't know what I'll do I'll just stay
here and be pissed
this camera needs to learn how to focus
me I did it I recorded a video in the
kitchen yes it took like three hours I'm
not even kidding
god dammit if you don't have like
hole-out sorry if you don't have the
stuff you're used to it gets hard
YouTube life
we're gonna go out now I think Mart's
yeah do you want to go we're going now I
don't know where oh god we're going to
well I ain't good will really happen
it's way too hot to be wearing black
this is a bad idea I don't understand
we're looking for groceries I have to go
in like 20 minutes
this is very interesting I bet for you
cool glad you agree why are you killing
me son look at that girl what a loser
alright so I just walked out of my house
and got mobbed by these guys and I guess
we're starting right away huh
no brakes hey how's going I'm beautiful
how can you not know me are you doing
the deterrent egg so funny I was
literally on Team C yesterday and they
have knowing it don't they keep up
they're not real fans oh my god they're
so we're basically doing an intro for
all that famous landmarks I'm surprised
I'm not dead yeah I'm home finally so
happy so we're at the hospital I'm ready
to do my exam I hope I pass
I probably one yeah standard hospital is
it going up what's up all right I'm
waiting for the doctor I'm alone in this
room
Lulu here so strange American hospitals
but so weird
today has been so weird I haven't how
much of it but it's been a weird day
I don't think I can film the actual
thing but I'll tell you how it goes
still doing the exam I have no idea like
it's going up American Hospital is a
[ __ ] weird
re this day is so weird okay I'm back
home this is the first day and I don't I
can't I can't tell you what happened
yeah is there i I had the weirdest day
of my life probably top three weirdest
day of my life I can't tell you what
happened
I'm so sorry you will see eventually but
my man man I
I am I am NOT okay look at me I'm let's
just say things got really weird in the
in the physical exam thing I'm glad
today's over it's not yet but I'm glad I
don't have to yes okay yeah I miss him
why'd you leave me boats okay we're at
my psychic beautiful italiano
bad-apple below door very good we're
gonna watch a movie even though it's
really late it's not late at all we're
still really jet-lagged but we're really
trying to go out and do stuff will
probably watch I hate to promote it you
know what I'll tell you honestly if you
should go and watch it or not afterwards
I'm gonna shape alright here we go
yeah
yeah you can see light now
it's too light now I already started are
you doing oh my god I lost five years
who is this tiny guy I think I look way
cleaner and nicer what do you both think
be honest you can just kiss me what do
you want
what do you want
hey I realize I have blood in my shoes
and the more I remember what happened
today the more I'm wearing it out I look
so young without the beard
what do all right cars here we gotta go
go girl
Deborah Deborah how can you not know
there's a cinema I love this area I
usually play at that hotel yes really
needed a beer for today I'm so
surprising a lot of it in the cinema I
asked like 6 times like do you really
American cinemas are so much better than
you can
like twice as big as the screen in UK
give me a three word review strange
silly and expected poop in the face back
home look we have a jack hoots hmm
we haven't tried it yet Adam oh my god
you scared okay we have a bug problem
apparently this concludes day three I
think yes I'm gonna do what I did today
tomorrow as well and I'm still gonna try
and vlog it I hope it works out if it
does let me know let me know if you
enjoy being a bro ooh that's a good one
either way just thank you for watching
and supporting these vlogs I'm sorry if
I sound really tired I'm just really jet
lag I'll see you bros tomorrow bro fish
yeah we'll let you bros know the biggest
secret of the universe how I do my hair